hey y'all this is Michelle from Iowa so
with the manna Knox getting married this
week it got me thinking for a debate
this foxy Knoxy innocent or guilty
thanks game getting is she guilty or
innocent she's the one that killed her
daughter right no she was no rot in
Italia in Italy and she got accused of
killing her roommate and spent yeah
definitely did it come on we had her on
this I don't think that she did it right
but I do think she look like she looks
like somebody oh she looks like somebody
could kill somebody that's she has a
look in her eyes sometimes like oh yeah
she could kill someone yeah dude it's
called dead behind the eyes because they
murder people you've seen Oh Jay Simpson
real life huh
you ever seen Oh Jason looks like you're
staring at a great white shark really
yeah Wow
her same [ __ ] boy tiny huh did you guys
have security here yes I saw the
documentary those things always you know
the wrong way we just talked about um
what did we talk about all kinds of
stuff yep she just got married and her
and her fiance came Chris was that his
name yeah and they loved Renaissance
Fairs yeah dude she couldn't murder look
how she's very leaning and kind of um uh
does she Kilcher you gotta be strong
estab someone I think you know you got
to be able to yeah yeah a little bit
little bit she's very like Connecticut
she dressed up like it's [ __ ] game uh
that's her wedding you don't link Quinn
yeah I know how [ __ ] batshit crazy
you gotta be to dress like [ __ ] Game
of Thrones on your wedding day it's a
Renaissance Fair theme and everybody get
those giant dinosaur turkey legs and
outer space I'm not sure what food they
had she already did it though watch the
doc dude just got it you did it I don't
think she did
now did she kidnap Marilyn Marilyn
McCann I don't know she could have done
that Nick you're awfully quiet over
there what do you think you're around
this killer
I think she's capable of murder but I
don't think she did it okay
now here's when you know if she kills
someone else that's how you know if
someone else around her dies usually
someone who's killing people can't only
kill one person as they can swishy the
roommate in Italy she didn't get away
with it
she had convicted of murder for God's
sakes she got she they were unsure she
seems like a great young lady and
there's a man Don Knotts and which is
the one that killed her kid and wants
more kids
Stacey Anthony Casey Casey Anthony
that's right and Scott Peterson killed
Casey Anthony didn't he then who killed
Jon Benet is it the same guy I'm
confused I don't know
I think japonaise brother killed her
Hanabusa oh my god I saw that thing but
I'll bring up JonBenet's brother you see
this no names on dr. Phil repeal you got
it get in here who did you guys believe
in serial killers or what do you got
well there's been two DC sniper and the
Madrid guy the nope the Atlantic the
Atlantic killer strangler oh wow Willie
what oh who you the brother Oh leave
that [ __ ] psycho he killed her
because she she ate his pineapple on
milk hit over the head then the parents
covered it up because they don't lose
both kids yeah you're like a song really
yeah yeah cold case not his neighbor
Larry Ramsey or something with the
brothers named Burke Burke Ramsey it
doesn't the jeweler yeah he probably has
been playing a pickup game or something
looking like Chris D'Elia in that last
picture go to that lat right there no
zoom in go in
just the up a little he definitely did
it though up a little more oh yeah I see
it
oh my god bro Burke D'Elia dude he
definitely did it though understand yeah
it was an accident Brendan if you killed
someone an accident you want to go to
jail forever for do you want your
parents to help you out yeah you're
right
here's another thing no man is chrisley
could definitely play this guy in him if
there was a biopic well Chris tell him
play a killer but he plays like a
pedophile not killer in you second
season yeah yeah but I want to see him
play this dude I want to see him play
Bert Bert Binet oh that's good that's
actually Chris D'Elia on the right
that's crazy
mix them up easily
[Music]